gourcuff ingelfinger es ich drücke ein
guten finger health club und jetzt
bekommen beim ein video
ich habe heute erst mal einfach recap
auf warum das so ist erfahrt ihr gleich
aber ich glaube ich hatte schon bestimmt
ein halbes jahr so was nicht mehr auf
deswegen fühlt sich sehr komisch an auf
jeden fall erstmal so wie das jetzt so
lange nichts kam
ich war viel unterwegs und war auch ein
bisschen kränklich und das resultat war
dann halt ich konnte nicht so viel für
youtube investieren warum ich jetzt der
cap auf ab ich habe mir hier eine
platzwunde geholt haben kopf und das ist
halt unter den haaren und ich kann meine
haare absolut nicht sein
deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade einen
körper vielleicht geht es morgen wieder
keine ahnung ich wollte nur allerdings
noch die wunde etwas in ruhe lassen
damit dass sich nicht entzündet oder
sonst was nun ja dennoch gibt es heute
von mir neues video und zwar habe ich
mich hingesetzt habe überlegt was kann
ich machen und ich bin in letzter zeit
wirklich sehr sehr viele auf amazon
unterwegs wir sind umgezogen wir
brauchen coole sachen für unsere wohnung
brauchen irgendeinen scheiß an die man
vorher nie gedacht hat aber ich habe mir
wirklich viel bei amazon bestellt und
bin da irgendwann mal auch so ein
produkt gestoßen wo ich mir gedacht habe
tiger was ist das warum gibt es also
dann habe ich halt ein bisschen
recherchiert und habe noch viel mehr
kranke dinge gefunden
die station wird als in diesem video
geht es um die kranke ssten dinge auf
ganz amazon ich zeige jetzt gleich mal
was ich da so zum teil gefunden hab ich
konnte leider noch nichts bestellen also
das weiß mehr seine spontane idee dieses
video zu drehen aber ich habe mir gleich
gedacht und zwar wenn die bock habt dass
ich mir auch mal sachen davon bestellen
und die man ein bisschen ausprobieren
oder testet dann schreibt einfach mal
und in die kommentare welche sachen ich
will davon bestellen soll
ich würde sagen bei 10.000 icx habe ich
dann das video raus kommt dann irgendwie
nächste woche oder sucht jetzt habe ich
schon wieder viel zu lange erzählt tut
mir leid
let's go okay erst war das erste produkt
das ist jetzt noch nicht so krank aber
ich wollte es auch auf jeden fall mit
rein nehmen weil ich dadurch habe die
ganzen anderen sachen gekommen und zwar
hat jemand über meine philipp link und
in den kommentaren
irgendwie hat er weiter gesurft das
müsste jetzt gar nicht verstehen auf
jeden fall habe ich gesehen
jemand hat sich wohl durch mich wie auch
immer ein bananen schneider bestellt die
einen apfel schneider verstehe ich noch
aber bananen schneider
ich meine wer schneidet so eine banane
bitte nicht einfach schnell und messer
tack tack tack tack tack tack tack nein
es gibt einen banalen
eine der wahrscheinlich gar nicht
funktioniert wie es in den kommentaren
steht dieses produkt ist der letzte müll
ein stern super ich mache weiter das
nächste produkt habe ich gestern erst
gefunden und zwar ist das ein raumspray
schicken 250 milliliter zur
raumbeduftung mit hühnersuppe luft und
spaß wäre es bitte gerne dass es zu
hause einfach im ganzen haus nach
hühnersuppe riecht mein mittel von
selbst da hinten der hat aber übers dort
musik das heißt er hat mich gerade nicht
wenn der bock habt dann würde ich das
mal bestellen und einfach noch voll in
seinem zimmer sprayer und mal gucken
aber das riecht ja heute als raumspray
knapp 250 megawatt produkt ich würde mal
kurz gern lesen was hier in den
kommentaren steht und reicht auch für
eine vier sterne bewertung aber ich
persönlich mag den verwesenden ratten
durch zwei oder brennender autoreifen
doch noch lieber
der geruch eines suppenhuhn es ist schon
toll verwesende ratte duftspray sänger
vincent was ist mit dir verwiesen hatte
durfte ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen
wonach das riecht so leute wir machen
weiter wir gehen von chicken zu schicken
und zwar habe ich gefunden
es gibt einfach eine warnweste nicht zu
uns menschen gibt es ja sowieso
nein wenn man einen hund aus bricht muss
es natürlich eine warnweste an haben
damit man es nicht übersieht es gibt
einfach warnwesten für habt ihr schon
mal 100 warnweste gesehen ich nicht
guckt euch mal hier bitte diese bilder
die das aussieht wie kommt man auf die
idee eine warnweste für hühner zu
erfinden
ich mein vielleicht ist es gar nicht so
schlecht wenn man jetzt bauer ist und
viele hühner hat und viele hühner
andauernd ausbrechen einfach jedem ohne
warnweste anziehen dann findet man es
leichter wieder aber diese scheiß weste
kostet 20 euro
ich glaube nun kostet vielleicht fünf
euro vj wieder essen nun ich muss jetzt
erst mal kurz raus finden wie teuer es
während der brutsaison bewegen sich die
preise für ein gängiges huhn im alter
von sechs bis zwölf monaten zwischen 10
und 15 euro das huhn kostet jetzt
einfach sagen wir mal zwölf euro und die
warnweste für das huhn 20 euro ja
absolut faire preise
so machen wir weiter auch mega geil das
produkt muss ich mir gleich sofort erst
mal bestellen und zwar haben wir hier
ein feature männer penis
auf dem regenbogen beutel mit kordel
verstellbare pflege g string penis will
wie lang ist die hülle unterhose brief
unterwäsche was ist das für name ja
leute die das vorher mal so leicht ihr
könnt wahrscheinlich die umrisse
erkennen es handelt sich hierbei halt um
so eine penis fülle ich wusste auch
nicht dass man so was bei amazon
bestellen kann
ich dachte immer dafür muss man ein
spezieller geschäfte gehen aber ist ja
gut für die zukunft jetzt weiß ich es
wenn ich werde mir sowas nicht bestellen
keine angst und das bringt auch nicht
wenn jetzt wirklich 10.000 kommentare
schreibt alex bestellt ihr das werde ich
nicht machen
300.000 vielleicht so leute und mein
absoluter favorit dessen sind nicht
wirklich überhaupt nicht verstehe
keine ahnung wofür was man damit machen
soll wieso sich das menschen kaufen aber
er ist gerade ausverkauft und zwar ist
dass der einzigartige gurken finger nur
köpfige finger es ich drücke ein guten
finger
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was man
mit diesem produkt anfangen soll habe
ich ja gerade schon gesagt so was würde
ich mir echt sehr gerne bestellen ist
halt nur wie gesagt gerade ausverkauft
wir schauen uns mal kurz die rezensionen
dazu an also was die leute dazu
geschrieben haben und zwar schreibt hier
einige meiner freunde haben sich den
gruppen finger bestellt und ich muss
sagen dass ich zuerst ein bisschen
skeptisch gegenüber diesem brach doch
allem ein zweifel könnte der gurken
finger durch seine hervorragenden
qualität schnell ausräumen der guten
springer war es einfach durch seine
unheimlich gute passform und das
ansprechende design zu begeistern alle
meine freunde sind falls nicht zufrieden
mit dem wirken finger
man muss dazu sagen dass meine freunde
äußerst kritisch gegenüber neuen
produkten sind auch vor einem vergleich
mit einer echten gewürzgurke muss sich
der guten finger nicht verstecken
unterschiede sind marginal
er kann auf ganzer linie überzeugen
daher fünf von fünf möglichen sternen
ticker läuft bei dir auf jeden fall
würde ich da auch fünf von fünf sternen
geben ich mein tolles produkt innovativ
kreativ so was braucht die welt voll auf
youtube youtube mutter google finger
wenig perfekt hinpassen ja weil sie so
viel dass wir dazu ich würde sagen wenn
ihren plan habe wo ich den gurten finger
her bekommen wir dann schickt mir das
dann werde ich mit dem bestellen und
schreibt auch oder schickt mir einfach
komische produkte kranke produkte eklige
produkte die ich mir dann zum nächsten
mal bestellen soll bei 10.000 gleicht
gibt dieses video folgt mehr aufs netz
oder instagram check mein job ab und wir
sehen uns dann
morgen wieder oder überhaupt rein